Alright so now that we have a sense of what tit for
tat does against various strategies, let's try to think about what we
should do against tit for tat, so what do we do if
we're facing tit for tat. So I'm just going to break it down
to two possibilities it turns out there's actually more, but these these
two are pretty instructive. So let's pretend that we have to choose
between always defect as a way of playing against tit for tat,
or we have to be always cooperate playing against tit for tat.
So what I've written down here is what the total discounted reward is going to
be or the total reward in this case. As a function of gamma. So, let's
start with what happens if you play
always cooperating against tit for tat. Well, you
already told me that it. Such a thing
will result in tit for tat always cooperating.
>> Mm Hm.
>> And that means we're going to play in
this box. The cooperate-cooperate box. And that means on
every single round, we're going to to get
a minus one. Which means over an infinite
run we're going to get an average of one, sorry minus one over one minus Gamma.
>> Mm Hm. That makes sense.
>> Okay? You agree with that?
>> I do. Just minus one repeated over and over again.
Now always defect as you recall you told me that, that will
result, well for the always defect agent against tit for tat, the
first thing that is going to happen is it's going to defect
while the tit for tat cooperates right? So we're
going to get zero for playing that strategy on the
first round. Zero doesn't sound very good but look
at the alternatives. They're all negative so zero's pretty good.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So it does this sort of you know good thing in the
first step then after that tit for tat responds by always defecting in
response. Right? And that means we're going to be stuck in this box
the defect defect box where you get minus sixes for the rest of ever.
>> Yes.
>> So that means minus six over one minus gamma. But that
starts one step from now so we multiply it by another gamma.
>> Okay.
>> Alright. So these are two different
expression that represents what our pay off
would be for adopting two different strategies.
And in fact, if gamma is really high,
very close to 1, then this is a really good answer, right? Because it sort of
grows, it's like, minus over one minus gamma. So, for high gamma, we're talking
about something that's minus one times a really big number.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Whereas this first one is not so good
for high gamma because what's going to happen is it's
going to get, end up getting minus six on every
step. So it's going to do worse overall. But if, if
we're talking about the low gamma. Then, let's say,
you know, zero for example. A gamma of zero will,
will always defect. We'll get zero plus zero. But
always cooperate, we'll get negative one over one. And zero
is better than minus one. So for really small
gamma, like if the games unlikely to last many
rounds, you should defect. But is the game is
going to last a long time, then you should cooperate.
>> I believe that.
>> Cool! Alright, so then my question to you is: What's the value of gamma
for which these two different strategies to
play against tit for tat are equally good.
>> I think I know the answer.
>> Woah! That was fast. Let's give everybody else
a chance to think about it.
>> Okay.
>> Go.